[Music]
hello
my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songsfromtestimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slepovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii blue buff k was born in 1921
in zvenigarotka ukraine the four pieces
two songs and two poems
she performed during her 1994
testimony about her experiences in the
labor
camps surrounding her hometown are
unique historical documents
telling the story of the camp prisoner's
everyday struggle for survival
the camps themselves the nearby villages
where the inmates used to escape to get
food
and step on camp guard are named in the
two of the four texts in decline indoors
from smil chansey in the small village
of smilchensi is a fascinating example
of the native yiddish speakers to
compose a song in german
under the harshest of conditions the
result is a mixed almost mecharonic text
largely in german with a few yiddishisms
mixed in
the song conveys the suffering of jewish
mothers
who were separated from their children
and longed for their homes
the style and form of the song
are reminiscent of the weimar republic
period
cabaret and theater songs very much
in the spirit of kurt vile an indirect
clue
that the song may not have been
originally composed
by the labor camp inmates in is the
widespread use
of popular songs with the new texts
during world war
ii
vince milchantsy
is
[Applause]
[Music]
see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
house
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
milchency was the second champ lipof was
taken to during her time as a forced
laborer on the transit highway 4 project
in german-occupied ukraine she was there
from the early summer of 1942
until december of that year as in
nyamrash the previous camp
your boyfriend her fellow prisoners
lived in a stable and slept on straw
on the floor in these camps the constant
threat of punitive executions and mass
shootings hung
over the prisoners in their early days
in the camps
the prisoners did not fully understand
the brutality of the german and
ukrainian camp guards
little did they know that the german
occupiers had designated
anyone incapable of work as quote
a superfluous mouth doomed to execution
as lebroff recalls quote we had just
arrived here to work
and we didn't know yet whether we had
the privilege of getting sick or not
four people fell ill three women
two women one girl and a boy
so they stayed in the barn they didn't
go to work
that evening when we returned from work
the john d'armery turned up unexpectedly
and had us line up outside along the
stable
they went inside the sick people were
lying in their beds
they pulled them up and shot them behind
the other stable
the girl who was sick managed to run
away but when she reached the fence
style to escape
she was met by selich a ukrainian guard
as duboif recalls quote he grabbed her
by the hair
and brought her back they shot her end
quote
what happened next is even more
heart-wrenching though
like many of the young folks in this
labor camp
the young girl who had been shot had
relatives still alive in this
vinigorodka ghetto
and at the time relatives from the
ghetto would periodically visit the camp
to bring their loved ones food
this girl's mother was among those
regular visitors
after the girl was shot the wolf and her
fellow prisoners couldn't bring
themselves to tell the mother what had
happened
so they told her to ask one of the
guards instead
he simply said i can't tell you anything
the mother persisted the prisoners
finally told her that the girl had
fallen
ill and that it was forbidden to enter
the camp
rather than deterring the mother this
prompted her to return to the camp for
the next
three days to bring food for her
daughter
and this lasted until the police i told
her what had actually happened
the mother lost her mind and then was
also shot
such stories played out over and over
again
in the camps inspiring the words of this
song
quote a child without a mother a mother
without a child the tears we've wept
could be rivers
the blood we've spilled could be an
[Music]
ocean
you